[Music]
we must now select my successor and to
tell me well man the opposition will
accept he stands for one thing and one
thing only himself why have I been
forced to send for ChaCha
his record is a catastrophe
let me see your true equality suit your
lack of vanity my will your sense of
humor oh ho ho your majesty it is my
duty to invite you to take up the
position of prime minister of this
United Kingdom I speak to you for the
first time as Prime Minister the Germans
have encircled 68 British and French
division we are looking at the collapse
of Western Europe with the next few days
how long have they got if we don't
rescue them maybe two days we would need
a miracle to get our men out the full
weight of the world on your shoulders
we're facing certain defeat online the
annihilation of our army an imminent
invasion we must be go shake these talks
when will the lesson be learned you
cannot reason with a tiger when your
head is in its mouth nonsense the only
slippery slope - stop interrupting me
while I am interrupting you we have
before us many many long months of
struggle and suffering
even though many old and famous states
are fallen into the grip of the nerves
in rule we shall defend our island
whatever the cost may be
we shall fight on the beaches we shall
fight on the landing grounds we shall
fight in the fields and in the streets
we shall fight in the Hills we shall
never
for we want victory there candy
[Music]